Rafael pues justamente el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva es
prácticamente el último que llega hasta
condena por parte de Naciones Unidas a
la invasión aquí Qué papel puede llegar
a tener América Latina con este tipo de
invitaciones que está recibiendo por
parte del presidente Pero hay un punto
importante Brasil es parte de los brics
exactamente y por eso en este juego
tridimensional y eventualmente
transversal hay sinergias importantes en
distintos sectores que vinculan a Brasil
con Rusia y recordemos que dentro de los
países estratégicos de América Latina
fueron Fernández y bolsonaron los dos
líderes que Durante este año visitaron
directamente a Vladimir Putin en Moscú
se escucharon diciendo que esas Cumbres
se preparan con mucho tiempo de
antelación que sin duda alguna era muy
complicado
evitarlas o renunciar a ellas pero
también lo hubieran podido hacer huir
ese sido una un involucramiento América
Latina siempre ha buscado mantener un
papel distante Por qué distante Santiago
porque la relación si bien América
Latina ha favorecido históricamente
principios como la autodeterminación de
los pueblos como el respeto al derecho
internacional y en este caso Rusia ha
violado esos principios también es
cierto que no quieren tomar partida
asumo Porque el involucramiento de los
Estados Unidos y en particular de la
organización del tratado del Atlántico
Norte que históricamente ha sido una
reivindicación de los distintos países
por eliminarla por su innecesario papel
en El Siglo 21 pues no los pone en una
posición cómoda a muchos de ellos así
mismo si analizamos cada una de las 33 o
34 realidades de América Latina nos
vamos a dar cuenta de que hay
exposiciones distintas una cosa es los
regímenes de Cuba Nicaragua y Venezuela
por ejemplo en los cuales ha habido
inversiones directas de importantes
empresas rusas de petróleo de gas y de
materiales preciosos y otros que tienen
unas relaciones comerciales más fluidas
como es el caso de Brasil como es el
caso de México y como es el caso de
Argentina y otros que si bien no gozan
de un comercio significativamente fluido
pues han tenido relaciones históricas
diplomáticas relativamente fuertes y que
no estarían dispuestos a apoyar a
Estados Unidos y la otan que que sería
como se traduciría a nivel interno o a
nivel regional este tipo de
involucramiento recordemos que los
países de la región han sido muy
críticos de la intervención de Estados
Unidos en pasadas crisis Como por
ejemplo la lucha contra el terrorismo
México y chile votaron de manera
negativa al interior del consejo de
seguridad en el año 2003 cuando se
propuso una intervención sin que hubiera
inspección por parte de la agencia de la
energía atómica en Irak y ese hecho
también refleja de que nosotros No
necesariamente ni colectivamente porque
es difícil que
individualmente ni individualmente
vayamos a dar un apoyo decidido a De
hecho si usted lo mira cuando uno cuando
se realizó la organización de los
Estados Americanos hace pocos meses el
presidente intervino de manera virtual
pero también han sido reticentes porque
ojo selinsky llega ahí por una serie de
casualidades Y si bien ha encarnado en
este año un importante liderazgo para
mantener unidas su nación y para
demostrar que hay resistencia pues
también hay profundas dudas acerca de él
después de este conflicto